[Music]
why use a state management library and
angular when you can just build your own
from scratch when you combine rxjs with
angular's dependency injection it
provides a powerful foundation for
building your own state management
system that means you can get all the
benefits of the redux pattern including
the dev tools that you see here on the
right but you can create your own
abstractions and conventions to reduce
the amount of boilerplate code plus
you'll have a much better understanding
of how your app works under the hood
over the next few minutes you'll learn
how to use custom rxjs operators and
multi casting to build your own state
management library but mostly I just
want to show you how this pattern works
at a fundamental level if you're new
like and subscribe and grab the source
code from angular firebase comm in case
you're not familiar with the redux
pattern here's a quick refresher the
whole idea is that we treat our app data
or state as a global immutable object
the only way we can change the current
state of the app is by dispatching an
action so that might happen on a button
click then the payload for that action
will go to a reducer function to
determine what the next state should
look like the store itself isn't
observable so everything will happen in
a reactive way so anything that
subscribes to the store will be updated
with the latest data the benefit of this
is that we now have a one-way data flow
that provides a predictable history of
all the changes that occur in the app so
we can do time-travel debugging and cool
stuff like that if we think about this
in code our current state is equal to
the stream of actions and the function
that reduces them a reducer is just a
pure function that takes in the current
state and the action and then returns
the next state so let's go ahead and
build this thing the first thing I want
to do is generate a service called store
and I'd also like to point out that I
have lodash installed not only will it
dramatically simplify our code but it
will also give us better performance
than we'd be able to achieve natively so
first I want to show you how our store
service will be used in a component one
really important concept in redux is
that our components should be stateless
meaning they should only be listening to
data from the store as an observable or
dispatching actions they shouldn't have
any state of their own so the service
will provide the store itself and then
also an action class which will just
give us a standardized way for creating
actions the store can be injected in the
constructor then the cool thing of
building your own state management
library is you can make it behave
however you want so in my case I want to
be able to grab properties with dot
notation this differs from say ng rx
where you'd use a callback function or a
pipe herbal operator to select your data
then there are three fundamental
credence that you're probably familiar
with if you work with no sequel
databases the first one is set which
will completely wipe out the store and
set it with new values so if we want to
reset the store will dispatch a new
action called set and that will include
the new data that we want to update but
we might also want to do a
non-destructive update for that will
create an update action and then we'll
tell a reducer to only update the
properties that are contained in the
data payload and the last one is delete
which as its action payload expects an
object property and then it will delete
that key from the store now remember all
of our data is just a global immutable
object as an observable so if we want to
view it in the UI we can just say store
dot state and then unwrap it with the
async pipe and then we also set a method
called select which will select a
specific slice of that state and setting
up that slicing is probably the most
complex thing that we'll have to do and
then lastly we'll set up a few buttons
here just to dispatch our actions then
the end result from the user's
perspective is just this UI with a few
buttons and then when clicked we get a
full history of every state change that
occurs so every time we click a button
you'll notice that it changes the state
in the UI and then we also have an event
in the Redux dev tools history overall
this is hugely beneficial for debugging
and also a lot easier to test now it's
time for the fun part
we're just here in a regular angular
service which is our store service I
have a few imports here from rxjs and lo
- then I'm creating my own custom action
class just to standardize the way
actions are dispatched you could also
make this an interface and then create a
different class for each action that's
the way it's done in ng Rx but in action
is super simple it's just a plain object
that has a type property which is a
string that defines the action that's
taking place and then it has an optional
payload that your reducer function can
use to construct the next state object
for the store now our service class
itself only has two properties the state
itself is our immutable data as an
observable and then our
actions are an rxjs subject which would
just be a stream of the action class
that we just created to make this
pattern super readable in the code I'm
going to create a custom rxjs operator
that we can pipe into our action stream
remember the state is 100% determined by
the actions so we can say our state
observable is equal to the actions which
will convert the actions to an
observable and then we can pipe in the
reducer operator that will create here
in the next step rxjs has an operator
called scan which will allow you to
accumulate values as they're emitted
through the observable to create a
custom operator in rxjs all you have to
do is create a function that returns an
existing operators such as scan and scan
provides two things first the
accumulated object which would be our
current state and also the current
action that was emitted through the
action stream subject now the only thing
we have to do is write some logic to
return the next state based on these two
input objects
traditionally in redux this is done with
a switch statement where we look at the
action type and then perform some logic
based on the type of action that was
dispatched but you don't necessarily
have to do it this way so if we have an
action type of set we'll go ahead and
set the next state as the action payload
which will just overwrite everything in
the state then if we have an update
action we'll go ahead and use the spread
syntax to merge the payload object into
the current state that will give us a
non-destructive update then if we're
going to delete a property we can use
the low - omit operator that's a lot
cleaner than trying to iterate through
all the object keys on your own so you
could pass delete either an object
property or an array of properties and
they would all be deleted from the state
in that action so that's all there is to
it we take the current state in the
action and use it to compose the next
state but we're not quite done yet we
still need to set up a way to dispatch
actions and also select a slice of the
state dispatching an action is super
easy all we have to do is write a method
here that takes an action as an argument
and then we'll go ahead and call actions
next and push that next action to the
stream now when it comes to selecting
data from the store things get a little
more tricky
the first issue we'll tackle is that
this observable should be shared between
all subscribers in other words we don't
want to create a new observable every
time
new subscription happens on the store on
top of that we want to make sure that a
new subscription always gets a value
when you have a hot observable and it
receives a new subscriber that
subscriber won't receive any data that
was emitted in the past well fortunately
we can solve all these problems with one
magical operator called share replay
this will ensure that all subscribers
are sharing the same source state and it
will also save the last emitted state so
new subscribers will always get a value
when they subscribe for the first time
now our last major hurdle is figuring
out how to select a slice of the state
or a nested object property and only
listen to changes on that slice once
again for that I'm going to create my
own custom rxjs operator it takes the
path as an argument which is just a
string and dot notation that points to
the object property that you want to
observe and again you don't have to make
this a custom operator I'm doing it
strictly for code readability it's going
to take the current state observable and
then map it down to a nested object
property lodash has a get method that
makes this super easy so we just called
get with the current state object and
then the path string that we want to
grab then as a third argument will pass
the default value if it doesn't exist
which can just be null now normally this
would emit the same object over and over
again because this nested state is still
tied to the parent observable but we can
create a really beautiful marriage
between rxjs and lodash here we take the
RX distinct until changed operator which
will only emit unique values but under
the hood it's using the regular
JavaScript equality operator that will
work for plain numbers and strings but
it won't work for any objects that get
emitted through the observable but we
can pass it the is equal function from
lodash which does a deep comparison on
object properties so now your sliced
observable will only emit new values if
the data that it's actually listening to
changes so that's pretty amazing for a
single line of code but now we're ready
for the moment that you've all been
waiting for
and that's wiring up Redux dev tools if
you don't have it installed yet you can
find it on the Chrome Web Store and it's
super easy to setup because under the
hood it's just using the same Redux
pattern that we've already implemented
in this app we can interact with it on
the window object in the browser so I'll
create a variable here for the window
then when the service is constructed
I'll go ahead and set it up as a
property on the window called dev tools
and we can find the extension and call
connect on it then the only thing left
to do is pass it the current action and
the state which we already have in our
reducer function so we can simply call
window dev tool send pass it the action
type and the next state and there's a
bunch can customize and configure dev
tools this is just your most basic use
case so hopefully that gives you an idea
of some of the fundamental principles
behind redux style state management
libraries like ng RX + ng XS if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to learn more
about stuff like this to get your
angular app in production consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase comm you'll get a free copy my
book as well as one on one project
support thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you soon